donc vous pouvez réellement rouler dans les 400 km.
CA : Ces batteries sont incroyablement lourdes,
mais vous pensez que ça peut quand même fonctionner
en combinant un corps léger et une batterie lourde,
on peut encore gagner une efficacité spectaculaire.
EM: Exactement. Le reste de la voiture doit être très léger
pour compenser le poids de la batterie,
et ensuite vous devez avoir un coefficient de traînée bas pour avoir une grande autonomie sur autoroute.
En fait, les clients du Model S
rivalisent entre eux
pour essayer d'atteindre la plus grande distance.
Je crois que quelqu'un a récemment reussi à atteindre les 675km avec une seule charge.
CA: Bruni Bowden, qui est ici, l'a fait,
il a battu le record mondial. EM: Félicitations.
CA : C'était la bonne nouvelle. La mauvaise, c'est que
pour faire cela, il a du conduire à la vitesse constante de 30km/h
et s'est fait arrêter par la police. (Rires)
EM : Mais vous pouvez certainement conduire --
si vous la conduisez à 100km/h
dans des conditions normales,
400 km est une distance raisonnable.
CA : Regardons cette deuxième vidéo
montrant la Tesla en action sur la glace.
Ce qui n'est pas une critique pour le New York Times.
Qu'est-ce qui est le plus surprenant
quand on conduit cette voiture ?
EM : Quand on construit une voiture électrique,
la réactivité de la voiture est vraiment incroyable.
Donc nous voulions vraiment que les gens ressentent
comme si leur esprit avait fusionné avec la voiture,
donc vous sentez que la voiture et vous ne faites qu'un
quand vous arrivez à une croisement et accélérer, c'est comme si
la voiture avait l'ESP.
Vous pouvez le faire avec une voiture électrique grâce à la réactivité.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire ça avec une voiture à essence.
Je pense que c'est une différence profonde,
et les gens ne ressentent que ça quand ils font un essai sur route.
CA : C'est une voiture superbe mais chère.
Est-ce qu'il y a un plan d'action
pour qu'elle devienne une voiture grand-public ?
EM : Oui, le but de la Tesla a toujours été
pensé comme un processus en 3 étapes :
la version 1 serait une voiture chère en petit volume,
la version 2 serait à prix moyen en volume moyen,
et la version 3 serait à bas prix, en grande quantité.
Donc nous en sommes à l'étape 2 pour le moment.
Nous avons eu une voiture de course à $100 000, la Roadster.
Ensuite nous avons la Model S, qui commence aux alentours de 50 000 dollars.
Et notre voiture de 3ème génération, qui devrait normalement
être disponible dans environ 3 ou 4 ans,
sera une voiture à $30 000.
Mais à chaque fois que vous avez une technologie vraiment nouvelle,
cela prend, en général, environ 3 versions majeures
pour la transformer en un produit grand-public attrayant.
Et donc je pense que nous faisons des progrès dans cette direction,
et je suis confiant, nous y arriverons.
CA : Mais, maintenant, si vous avez une petite distance à faire,
vous pouvez conduire, vous pouvez rentrer chez vous et la recharger à la maison.
Il n'y a pas d'immense réseau, à travers le pays, de stations électriques qui soient rapides.
Est-ce que vous voyez cela arriver, vraiment, sincèrement,
ou alors juste sur quelques grands axes routiers ?
EM : Il y a en fait bien plus de stations électriques
que ce que les gens ne pensent
et à Tesla, nous développons quelque chose
que nous appelons une technologie de Super-chargement
et nous le proposons quand vous achetez une Model S,
gratuitement, pour toujours.
C'est peut-être quelque chose qu'un grand nombre de personnes ne réalise pas.
En fait, nous avons couvert la Californie et le Nevada,
ainsi que le bord de mer de la côte Est
depuis Boston jusqu'à Washington.
D'ici à la fin de cette année, vous pourrez conduire
de Los Angeles jusqu'à New York
juste en utilisant le réseaux de Super-chargement,
qui recharge 5 fois plus vite que n'importe quoi d'autre.
Et la clé de tout ça, c'est d'avoir un ratio de conduite sur arrêt,
sur temps d'arrêt, d'environ 6 ou 7.
Donc si vous conduisez 3 heures,
vous voulez vous arrêter pour 20 ou 30 minutes,
car c'est ce que les gens font généralement.
Donc si vous commencez votre voyage à 9h du matin,
d'ici à midi vous voulez vous arrêter pour manger,
aller au toilette, prendre un café puis repartir.
CA : Donc ce que vous vendez, c'est, pour la recharger à fond, ça peut prendre une heure.
C'est assez commun - ne vous attendez pas à ressortir dans 10 minutes.
Attendez une heure, mais la bonne nouvelle,
c'est que vous aidez à sauver la planète.
Et au fait, l'électricité est gratuite. Vous ne payez rien
EM : En fait, ce que nous espéront c'est que les gens
s'arrêtent environ 20 à 30 minutes, pas une heure
C'est en fait mieux de rouler environ 250km
et de s'arrêter une demi-heure
puis de repartir.
C'est le rythme naturel d'un voyage.
CA : D'accord. Donc c'est une seule corde à votre arc énergétique.
Vous avez travailler sur cette compagnie solaire, SolarCity.
Qu'est-ce qui est insolite là-dedans ?
EM : Eh bien, comme je l'ai dit plus tôt,
nous devons avoir une production électrique renouvelable
ainsi qu'une consommation renouvelable,
donc je suis sûr que les moyens premiers
de création de courant seront solaires.
Je veux dire, c'est vraiment de la fusion indirecte.
Nous avons cet énorme générateur de fusion dans le ciel, appelé soleil,
et nous devons juste recueillir un peu de cette énergie
pour les besoins de la civilisation humaine.
Ce que les gens savent mais ne réalisent pas
c'est que le monde fonctionne déjà entièrement au solaire.
Si le soleil n'était pas là, nous serions une boule de glace
à 3° Kelvin (-270°C),
et le soleil fait fonctionner le système entier des précipitations.
Tout l'écosystème fonctionne au solaire.
CA : Mais dans un litre d'essence, vous avez
en fait, des milliers d'années de puissance solaire
comprimées dans un petit espace,
donc il est difficile de changer les chiffres en faveur du solaire
et de concurrencer de loin, disons, le gaz naturel.
Comment allez-vous construire un business là-dessus ?
EN : En fait, je suis sûr que le solaire
battra tout le reste sur le terrain, y compris le gaz naturel.
(Applaudissements) CA : Comment ?
EM : Il le doit, en fait. S'il ne le faisait pas, nous aurions de gros problèmes.
CA : Mais vous ne vendez pas de panneau solaire au consommateur.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
EM : Non, en fait, nous le faisons. Vous pouvez acheter un système solaire
ou bien en louer un.
La plupart des gens choisissent de le louer.
Et le truc à propos du courant solaire, c'est que
il ne consomme rien et n'a pas de coût opérationnel,
une fois qu'il est installé, il est juste là.
Il fonctionne pendant des dizaines d'années. Il fonctionnera probablement pendant un siècle.
Donc la chose à faire est
de trouver un coût d'installation initiale bas
et ensuite d'obtenir un coût de financement bas,
car ce sont les deux facteurs de coûts du solaire.
Et nous avons fait d'énormes progrès dans cette direction,
et c'est pourquoi je suis confiant que nous arriverons à battre le gaz naturel.
CA : Donc ce que vous vendez maintenant, c'est
ne payez pas autant au début.
EM : Zéro. CA : Payez zéro au début.
Nous installerons des panneaux sur votre toit.
Vous paierez ensuite. Combien de temps dure généralement ces locations ?
EM : Généralement les locations sont pour 20 ans,
mais l'offre, comme vous le mentionnez, est assez simple.
C'est aucun coût au début et une réduction de votre facture.
Une offre sympa.
CA : Donc on dirait que les clients sont gagnants.
Pas de risque, vous paierez moins que maintenant.
Pour vous, le rêve, ici, c'est que --
je veux dire, à qui appartient l'électricité de ces panneaux sur le long terme ?
Comment est-ce que vous, la compagnie, faites des profits ?
EM : Eh bien, essentiellement,
SolarCity lève beaucoup de capital
à travers, par exemple, une compagnie ou une banque.
Google est l'un de nos gros partenaires là-dessus.
Et ils ont un retour sur capital attendu.
Avec ce capital, SolarCity achète et installe les panneaux sur un toit
et ensuite charge le propriétaire de la maison ou de la compagnie
un loyer mensuel, qui est moins cher que la facture.
CA : Mais vous-même obtenez un avantage commercial à long-terme de cette energie.
C'est comme si vous construisiez un nouveau type d'énergie distribuée.
EM : Exactement. Ça revient à créer
une énergie distribuée géante.
Je pense que c'est une bonne chose car les énergies
ont constitué une source de monopole et les gens n'avaient pas le choix.
Donc c'est la première fois
qu'il y a une compétition pour ce monopole,
car les compagnies d'énergies ont été les seules
qui possédaient ces lignes de distribution, mais maintenant c'est sur votre toit.
Donc je pense que c'est réellement une prise de contrôle
par les propriétaires et les compagnies.
CA : Et vous imaginez réellement un futur
où la majorité du courant aux États-Unis,
d'ici les 10-20 ans, ou d'ici une vie, va devenir solaire ?
EM : Je suis extrêmement confiant que le solaire sera source d'au moins une grande partie du courant,
et très probablement de la majorité.
Et je prédis que ça sera une grande partie dans moins de 20 ans.
J'ai fait ce pari avec quelqu'un. CA : Votre définition d'une grande partie ?
EM : Plus de solaire que provenant d'autre source.
CA : Ah. Avec qui avez-vous fait ce pari ?
EM : Avec un ami dont je tairais le nom.
CA : Juste entre nous. (Rires
EM : J'ai fait ce pari il y a 2 ou 3 ans, je crois,
donc dans environ 18 ans,
je pense que nous verrons plus d'électricité venir du solaire que de n'importe quelle autre source.
CA : D'accord. Revenons à un autre pari que vous avez fait
avec vous-même, une sorte de pari fou.
Vous avez fait de l'argent lors de la vente de PayPal.
Vous avez décidé de construire une compagnie spatiale.
Pourquoi diable quelqu'un ferait-il ça ?
(Rires)
EM : On me pose souvent cette question, c'est vrai.
Les gens me demandent : « Est-ce que tu connais la blague du mec
qui a investi une petite fortune dans une compagnie spatiale ? »
Et bien sur, la chute : « Il a commencé avec une grosse fortune »
Et donc je dis aux gens que j'essayais de trouver
le moyen le plus rapide de transformer une grosse fortune en une petite.
Et ils me regardent du genre : « Est-ce qu'il est sérieux ? »
CA : Et bizzarement, vous l'étiez. Que s'est-il passé ?
EM : Il s'en est fallu de peu. Les choses ont presque échoué.
Nous sommes passés très près de la catastrophe,
mais nous avons réussi à surpasser cela en 2008.
Le but de SpaceX est d'essayer de faire avancer la technologie des fusées,
et particulièrement d'essayer de résoudre un problème
que je crois vital
pour l'humanité, devenir une civilisation de voyageurs de l'espace,
ce qui veut dire avoir une fusée totalement réutilisable rapidement.
CA : Est-ce que l'humanité va devenir une civilisation de voyageurs de l'espace ?
Donc c'est un de vos rêves, dans un sens, depuis un jeune âge ?
Vous avez rêvé de Mars et de l'au-delà ?
EM : J'ai en effet construit des fusées quand j'étais enfant,
mais je ne pensais pas que je m'impliquerais là-dedans.
C'est vraiment plus du point de vue de définir
qu'elles sont les choses qui ont besoin d'arriver afin
que le futur soit excitant et inspiratif ?
Et je pense réellement qu'il y a une différence fondamentale,
si vous regardez le futur,
entre une humanité faite de voyageurs de l'espace,
qui est là-bas, explorant les étoiles, sur de multiples planètes,
et je pense que c'est vraiment excitant,
comparé à une humanité qui serait pour toujour confinée sur Terre
jusqu'à un évenement d'extinction ultime.
CA : Donc vous avez taillé dans le coût de production
d'une fusée de 75%, suivant comment vous calculez cela.
Comment diable avez-vous fait ça ?
La NASA fait ça depuis des années. Comment avez-vous fait ?
EM : Nous avons fait des avancées significatives
dans la technologie du fuselage, des moteurs,
de l'électronique et du lancement.
La liste des innovations que nous avons
mis en place est longue
et il est un peu difficile de la citer dans ce discours mais --
CA : Ne serait-ce que parce que vous pourriez être copié, n'est-ce pas ?
Vous n'avez pas breveté tout ça. C'est très interessant.
EM : Non, nous ne brevetons pas. CA : Vous n'avez pas breveté car vous pensez que
c'est plus dangereux de breveter que de ne pas breveter ?
EM : Puisque nos principaux concurrents sont des gouvernements nationaux,
l'exécution de ces brevets est douteuse. (Rires) (Applaudissements)
CA : C'est vraiment très intéressant.
Mais la grande innovation est toujours devant nous,
et vous travaillez dessus actuellement. Dites-nous en plus.
EM : Donc cette grande innovation --
CA : En fait, regardons cette vidéo et vous pourrez nous décrire ce qui se passe dedans.
EM : Tout à fait. Donc le truc à propos des fusées,
c'est qu'elles sont toutes accessoires.
Toutes les fusées qui volent aujourd'hui sont entièrement accessoires.
La navette spatiale était un essai pour une fusée réutilisable,
mais même le réservoir principal de la navette spatiale était éjecté à chaque fois,
et les pièces qui étaient réutilisables
prenaient 9 mois à un groupe de 10 000 personnes pour être restaurées pour un vol.
Donc la navette spatiale finissait par coûter un milliard de dollar par vol.
Bien sur, ça ne fonctionne pas bien pour --
CA : Qu'est-ce qui se passe ici ? Nous avons vu un truc atterrir ?
EM : C'est vrai. Donc il est important que les étages de la fusées
puissent revenir, retourner au site de lancement
et être prêt pour un nouveau lancement en quelques heures.
CA : Wow. Des fusées réutilisables. EM : Oui. (Applaudissements)
Et donc ce que beaucoup de gens ne réalisent pas, c'est que
le coût du carburant, du propulseur, est très petit.
C'est comme un avion.
Donc le coût du propulseur est d'environ 0.3%
du coût de la fusée.
Donc il est possible d'atteindre une amélioration
d'environ 100 fois le coût du vol spacial
si vous pouvez réellement réutiliser la fusée.
C'est pourquoi c'est si important.
Chaque mode de transport que nous utilisons,
que ce soit les avions, les trains, les voitures, les vélos, les chevaux,
sont réutilisables, mais pas les fusées.
Donc nous devons résoudre ce problème afin de devenir une civilisation de voyageurs de l'espace.
CA : Vous m'avez demandé plus tôt
à quel point les croisières seraient populaires
si vous deviez brûler votre navire. EM : Certaines croisières sont apparement très problématiques.
CA : Certainement plus chères.
Donc c'est potentiellement une technologie de rupture totale,
qui, je suppose, ouvre la voie à votre rêve de réellement,
à un moment donné, amener l'humanité sur Mars à grande échelle.
Vous aimeriez voir une colonie sur Mars.
EM : Oui, exactement. SpaceX ou une combinaison
d'entreprises et de gouvernements, a besoin de faire des progrès
en direction de mettre la vie sur plusieurs planètes,
d'établir une base sur une autre planète,
sur Mars -- la seule option réaliste --
et ensuite construire cette base
jusqu'à ce que nous soyons une vraie espèce multi-planète.
CA : Donc les progrès sur le « Construisons la réutilisable »,
comment cela avance ? C'est seulement une vidéo de simulation que nous avons vu.
Comment cela avance-t-il ?
EM : Nous sommes en fait, nous avons fait de bons progrès récemment
avec quelque chose que nous appelons le Projet Test Sauterelle,
où nous testons la partie de l'atterrissage vertical du vol,
en gros, la dernière portion du vol qui est assez délicate.
Et nous avons eu de bons tests.
CA : Est-ce que nous pouvons voir ça ? EM : Oui.
Donc c'est juste pour donner un ordre de grandeur.
Nous avons déguisé un cowboy comme Johnny Cash
et l'avons scotché à la fusée. (Rires)
CA : D'accord, voyons la vidéo alors
car c'est vraiment incroyable quand on y pense.
Vous n'avez jamais vu cela avant. Une fusée décoller puis...
EM : Oui, et donc la fusée fait la taille
d'un immeuble de 12 étages.
(Lancement de fusée)
Maintenant elle vole à environ 40m
et elle est constamment en train d'ajuster
l'angle, l'inclinatison et l'embardée du moteur principal,
et de maintenir la poussée avec des propulseurs de gaz de houille.
CA : Est-ce que c'est pas cool, ça ? (Applaudissements)
Elon, comment avez-vous fait ?
Ces projets sont si -- Paypal, SolarCity,
Tesla, SpaceX, ils sont si spectaculairement différents
ce sont des projets d'envergure tellement ambitieux.
Comment diable est-ce qu'une personne
a été capable d'innover comme cela ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a chez vous ?
EM : Je ne sais pas, en fait.
Je n'ai pas de réponse à cette question.
Je travaille beaucoup. Je veux dire, vraiment beaucoup.
CA : Eh bien, j'ai une théorie. EM : D'accord.
CA : Ma théorie c'est que vous
avez la capacité de penser au niveau du système de conception
qui fait tenir le tout : conception, technologie et business,
donc si TED était TBD : Technology Business et Design
dans un seul lot,
synthétisé d'une manière comme peu de personne peut le faire et --
et c'est le plus critique -- totalement confiant
avec ce lot qui s'emboite, vous prenez des risques fous
Vous pariez votre fortune là-dessus et vous semblez l'avoir fait de nombreuses fois.
Je veux dire, presque personne ne peut faire ça.
Est-ce... Pourrions-nous avoir un bout de cette recette secrète ?
Peut-on l'intégrer dans notre système scolaire ? Est-ce que quelqu'un peut apprendre de vous ?
C'est vraiment incroyable ce que vous avez fait.
EM : Eh bien, merci.
Je pense vraiment qu'il y a une bonne structure de penser.
C'est physique. Vous savez, un genre de principes premiers du raisonnement.
Générallement je pense qu'il y a... Ce que je veux dire par là,
revenons aux vérités premières
et raisonnons depuis cela,
plutôt que de raisonner par analogie.
La plupart du temps, nous passons notre vie
à raisonner par analogie,
ce qui veut dire essentiellement copier ce que d'autres font avec quelques petites différences.
Et vous devez faire cela.
Sinon, mentallement, vous ne pourriez pas survivre à une journée.
Mais quand vous voulez faire quelque chose de nouveau,
vous devez appliquer l'approche de la physique.
La physique, c'est réellement savoir comment découvrir
de nouvelles choses qui sont contre-intuitives, comme la mécanique quantique.
C'est réellement contre-intuitif.
Donc je pense que c'est une chose importante à faire,
ainsi que de vraiment faire attention aux retours négatifs,
et de les solliciter, particulièrement auprès d'amis.
Ça peut paraître un simple conseil,
mais très peu de personnes le font,
et c'est incroyablement utile.
CA : Garçons et filles qui nous regardent, étudiez la physique.
Apprenez de cet homme.
Eon Musk, j'aimerai que nous ayons toute la journée, mais merci beaucoup d'être venu à TED.
EM : Merci. CA : C'était génial. C'était vraiment vraiment cool.
Regardez ça. (Applaudissements)
Vous pouvez le saluer. C'était fantastique.
Merci beaucoup.